It: Chapter One scared the pants off of audiences
when it debuted in 2017, becoming the highest-grossing
horror movie of all time and leaving fans
hungry for more.
And It: Chapter Two is certainly keeping pace
with its predecessor at the box office.
According to the Los Angeles Times,
"[The film] scored $91 million in its first
weekend, making it the second-biggest horror
movie opening of all time, behind its 2017
predecessor."
"...Hello."
Together, the two films are likely to rake
in a worldwide box office take somewhere in
the neighborhood of $1.5 billion dollars.
And this begs the question: Will there be
an It: Chapter Three?
Please note: We'll be discussing a few plot
points from King's novel and the two films,
so some spoilers are coming right at you!
While both It movies were reasonably faithful
to the source material, Stephen King's epic
1986 novel of the same name, they weren't
completely so.
Several set pieces solely appear in the films…like
Stan's run-in with the creepy lady from the
painting in the first film…and Bill's hall-of-mirrors
nightmare in the second.
One of the most notable changes is the fact
that It: Chapter Two doesn't end with the
same city-destroying storm that concludes
the book.
This difference could be telling.
Following the success of It: Chapter One,
studio execs may have advised director Andy
Muschietti to leave the door open for a third
installment.
But if that's the case, he certainly isn't
admitting it.
In 2017, he did discuss the possibility of
splitting Chapter Two into seperate films,
telling Variety:
"It would make sense because it would give
me more turf to develop the characters and
more of a canvas to develop the journey, but
to be honest, there wasn’t a conversation
about that and now we are designing the story
as one single film."
Of course, nothing motivates studio executives
like big bucks…and if New Line ultimately
decides to greenlight a third chapter, there's
a number of tracks the film could take.
In fact, Pennywise actor Bill Skarsgård has
mentioned that he and Muschietti have kicked
around an idea for a third It movie.
In a recent sitdown with JoBlo, the actor
opened up about those talks, saying that
"Andy and I have discussed ideas for what
a third movie would look like.
I don't think it's quite what people expect.
It's something different.
The first two stories are the book, and the
second film is the end of that story.
So we would do something quite literally off
book."
Skarsgård goes on to reveal that
"There are a few ideas floating around.
I feel like I've done what I can with the
incarnation of Pennywise as we know of him,
so I think it would be a cool idea to change
up a few things.
So, without going into too much detail, there
is a story that we're kind of excited about,
but it's way too early to say.
But we'll see, we'll see."
The idea of a new "incarnation" of Pennywise
is certainly an intriguing one, although it's
safe to say there are about a million ways
to get that concept wrong.
Obviously, any additions to King's masterpiece
would require a deft touch, but at least Muschietti
has already demonstrated his considerable
talent just by bringing It successfully to
the big screen.
Of course, even if It: Chapter 3 never comes
to fruition, Pennywise could always return
to theaters in a supercut of the first two
films.
And guess what?
Muschietti has definitely considered the idea,
as he recently told CinemaBlend:
"I am thinking of a supercut.
Which is basically the two movies told one
after the other, adding everything that was
lifted from them for length purposes.
Great scenes that are more character moments,
or things that we had to lift for other reasons.
I’m also very excited about shooting extra
material."
Well, that news should certainly put a smile
on your face.
Of course, if that plan comes to fruition,
we hope we're given an intermission or two…because
watching an It supercut would certainly gobble
up a gargantuan amount of time.
Considering that Muschietti has already put
this idea out in the public sphere, we're
thinking a supercut could actually happen.
As to whether we'll ever really see an It:
Chapter Three, we suspect that the likelihood
is pretty slim.
And all things considered, that's probably
for the best.
The novel spins an epic and phenomenally terrifying
yarn…but expanding the story would almost
certainly do the book a disservice.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one!